Um,
how did you wind up living in Mexico City?
So I,
I came to Mexico or went to
Mexico in the year 2000 and uh,
I kind of messed around
for a few years in the UK.
What did the game to journalism.
So I found one way to get into it was
to start working in a foreign country
rather than going to my local newspaper
and work and go to a foreign country and
start working and had a romantic idea
about Latin America, thinking I'd be like,
I saw the movie Salvador. Ah, you know,
Oliver Stone's movie from the 80s.
I kind of had a, had a, had
a romantic idea about running
around with grillers, um,
fighting military dictatorships.
Um,
so I arrived in Mexico
in 2000 and got a job at,
I had an English language newspaper.
How old were you?
27 when I first left the UK.
Yeah,
28 when I mess around for
a bit in Mexico as well.
And then got the job when I was 28.
Mexico City is a wild place. Yeah. Yeah.
It's so packed. It's, it's hard to,
I've only been there twice
for a UFC events. Yeah.
But every time I'm there
I'm just shaking my head.
Like I can't believe how it's
traffic works. It's crazy. Yeah.
18 years and nothing,
a lot of time in that traffic.
Nobody cares about red lights,
green lights, they don't care.
It's stressful at Evelyn. Cut. Who
wants to cut you up all the time? Yeah.
People shout at you a lot.
You'd have to get used to people
calling you like Ben Deco Salvador.
I tried different tactics, not
just one, relax and not get angry.
Did you know how to speak Spanish
before you went there? Yeah. Yeah.
So I spent one year in Spain living in
Spain before I went there and spent a
year in the Middle East
as well. Um, and uh, but yeah,
I started off when I arrived I
spoke more to Spanish, Spanish,
which is like all yet DLC on your deal.
And then I change more to like the
Mexican Spanish, which is like,
or your way keep us all away.
Right, right, right. Yeah.
So when did you start getting
into narco journalism?
So like I arrived, say with a romantic
idea about why might cover in, in,
uh,
in Mexico or Latin America and right away
realize all that idea of grillers and
military dictatorships that are, that
are gone. That was the last century,
Che Guevara, all that stuff out of
gone. But right away when I arrived,
my very first of all,
first back in the UK,
I grew up around a lot of drugs in the UK.
So going back to the eighties,
I grew up a lot of people taking drugs.
I had a few friends who died from heroin
overdoses back then for people I knew
died of heroin overdoses.
I had a sister who went,
who became a schizophrenia
smoking a lot of,
a lot of winner.
She was,
became schizophrenic and there'd be a lot
of drugs being smoked around that time
as well.
Was it pot? Yeah, back then it was
a Moroccan hashish. There's, there,
there is a connection, you know, and
we've been exploring that a lot lately.
We went into this, uh, marijuana
debate between, um, uh,
Alex Bernstein and I'm Dr. Mike Hart
from Canada and we talked about it.
And I know people that have
had that happen to them or
they've had schizophrenia
or a psychotic breaks
because of just massive doses
of marijuana.
And especially people that don't do it
or people that do it too much for too
long. It does happen. I had that debate.
That's one of the reasons why
it came to mind. Uh, I mean,
I don't know a lot of people smoke weed,
smoke hash while people,
it's fine now when,
when my sister had a breakdown when she
was 18 and I was 16 at a time and when
that came out it turned out also my,
my,
my grandmother had an issue
with schizophrenia and I think,
I don't know if it's a time bomb waiting
to go off or if it was how much the,
the, the hatch was involved in
that. There's other issues as well.
So I don't really know the science
of it, but Ben way going back. So,
so I've been around a lot of drugs
before. Um, so when I arrived in Mexico,
actually one of the first,
uh, first arriving in Mexico,
I ended up hanging around with some,
some people and they were smoking
a lot of crack in, in Mexico.
It's one of some of the first people I
met. Wow. Um, I went down to the beach,
like backpacking down to the beach and
these people were smoking, smoking crack.
And I was like,
this is kind of strange.
I didn't know those people
smoking crack down here.
So when I got a job at the
local newspaper in English,
and I just started looking
at the crime thing,
one of the first deals I did was on the
issue of crack being sold locally and
how that linked her to cartels. And
then very soon does very, very quick.
I just fell in right away. Like I said,
are these things happen by accident?
I just fell into covering the crime
beat and this is going back to 2001.
So 2001, it was the same year that
chapel was man escaped from prison. Uh,
then I was calling a lot then to
a great journeys from twiner has,
is blank on Ellis.
You're a real legend from Tijuana
who survived the shooting by it,
by cartels and you know,
phoning him up all the time.
Just getting him and had given me
information can be tips and that is how it
really started with it. And our big
store, I did it back in those days was a,
the court marshal of some
generals for drug trafficking.
And that was really where it began back
then. Generals for drug trafficking.
How much of an issue is that? Uh, I mean,
corruption must be unbelievably rampant.
So I mean, corruption even isn't
a strong enough word for it. Um,
sometimes I call it state capture.
I mean,
so this is the real beginning and this
has been a whole crazy 18 years of
covering this stuff. And this is
just the very beginning back then.
I've seen a whole lot of
crazy stuff in that time.
But like just to get a sense of
how bad the corruption is or,
or what it really means. And on,
on the ground level, they're like,
there's a policemen let
you interview policemen,
you get to know the policemen in
a certain town, certain city. Um,
and it's hard to know now or,
or military guys are politicians and you
want to believe these are good people.
You want to believe there's good policemen
out there who really want to stop
crime. So there was one policeman,
his nickname was tight at Dyson,
like Mike Tyson, his nickname was Tyson
because he was a well built bloke,
well built guy and uh,
he was friendly with depressed
governed from Mitchell,
friend friendly would depress.
Um,
and then it came out that he was actually
a drug cartel member ranking member in
a drug cartel. And he
actually confessed, they,
they used to have a thing where
the police, the federal police,
when they got him going to confess
on camera and he confessed,
not only was he turning a blind eye,
not only was he carrying out murders,
he was training the young kids how to the
capitate people, how to cut people up.
And it was expanding in graphic
detail how he like in a,
how they might have to cut limbs off,
how it gives young people train the cut
limbs off to get them to lose their fear.
So that's the level of corruption that
could be a policeman you're dealing with
and that's really who they are.
Um,
so that's one of the crazy things
about a corruption down there.
Did you have any hesitancy in getting
involved in narco journalism knowing this?
I mean,
I would imagine that's one of the
most dangerous avenues to pursue in
journalism. So this was little by
little, I got involved in covering this.
So like it like going back to
2000 and this hadn't happened,
this war hadn't happened. It was still
like a crime issue at that moment.
So I began to cover these things and
then around 2004 I got a job for the
Houston chronicle out of
Houston, Texas. I was covering,
I was a stringer covering Mexico for them
and I flew up to a lot to Nuevo Laredo
and there was a turf war beginning there,
which is really the beginning of the
drug war, which is toward Mexico.
Part began on the border with Texas in
this city called Nuevo Laredo over the
bridge from Laredo,
Texas back in 2004 so there was a lot
of interest from the Texas newspapers,
what was going along as a whole bunch
of bodies piling up there. But again,
it's going back to these days and
this is kind of innocent looking back,
innocent, looking at myself. Then an
innocent looking at what Mexico is like.
Then they would simply say, go to
the place, I draw up the Monterey,
rent a car,
and just drive the car to Norbury
either with bus by myself.
And now people just don't do that. There's
just too much crazy stuff going on.
But back then it was still
light or you can just do that.
So there was this crazy stuff, like
what kind of crazy stuff? I mean,
now you can get stopped by an armed
group driving on those roads. He could,
you could just drive along and it could
be a group of guys with guns could stop
the car, get someone out,
takes, take your way. I mean,
there's a whole people a lot more careful
about, you know, where you are now now.
And um,
when you move around a roads that you've
gotta be very careful how you move and
how you plan this stuff. He didn't just
wander by yourself. Dry ran his places.
So, so back then when this was
happening and um, there was, uh,
these body turning up and I was trying
to figure out why. And, and I, uh,
there was one a guy interviewed who
was a head of chamber of commerce.
Um, and, uh, talk to me, no very
guy. About a couple of weeks later,
he became the chief of police for
the city and they asked him and said,
are you scared? Um, and I used to
get about being killed. He said, no,
I'm not scared.
I said,
of the corrupt people who get killed
and he was shot dead six hours after he
gave that statement, they shot him dead.
And that was one of the real markers.
If something really strange
is going on in Mexico,
something is like going
to erupt in Mexico. Uh,
and then from there it kind of just
escalated and escalated and uh, um,
started working by the other media,
Time magazine, New York Times,
different people in after what I said,
I can't do the [inaudible] right.
New stores about it.
It's got to write books about this
because this stuff is big and it's
complicated.
It must be immensely complicated
for the people that live there.
It seems like there's no escape.
I mean, if you, you can't
turned to the police, the police are the
cartel. There's the cartel, the police,
all of the politicians, most likely if
they're alive, have to be compromised.
Yeah. I mean there's been some varied,
very desperate people and I mean,
there's been some bird has
been some inspirational
people as well. Fight in this.
There's been heroes. There are heroes. Um,
just to get more of a sense of what that
means on the ground as well. Uh, I and I,
and some of the things
you see, uh, you know,
some of the things that stay
with me in Africa for a while,
it was quite romantic covered next.
It was like, wow, I'm covering,
I'm going to these places where Chapo
goes, man is from, you know, what,
I've got up to the village of me's mother
meets family. I'm writing about these,
these crazy people. But then you start
seeing the, the human pain in all of this.
Um, one of many stories that stick
with me was a mother in Monta Ray,
a school teacher. You know, when
you have arm guys moving around,
they're also like,
uh,
really effecting the civil population
had attack and the civil population and
one mother,
um,
she was in our home with our
two children in Monterey and a,
it was like in the night just chilling
in their house and in the door broke down
and about 15 guys in bulletproof
jackets or came in long arms,
just taking stuff from the house, held
the family, you know, pinned him down.
And I said to the mother,
which of your children as the oldest?
And she was like, didn't know how to
reply. I mean, which of your children?
The oldest, how do I, how do I reply
to that? She just couldn't speak.
And the eldest, Satya
Tucson's one 18, one 15,
the 18 year old was a
philosophy student and he said,
um, I'm on the oldest, said,
okay, you're coming with us.
And took him away. The next day
she got a phone call saying, oh,
could got your sign, give us this
amount of money. We'll give them back.
So she went round to like
relatives just got the money,
she wants to get the money right away.
She turned up with the money,
gave some money and then they just cut
off the court and she hadn't heard from
him since.
And I miss seeing her face devastation.
Um, the page that I,
you know, just couldn't,
couldn't go with life after that and
just not knowing, not having the closure.
And I met her when I went to report
on one of the worst atrocities,
which was 49 bodies who'd
all been decapitated or had
their hands and feet cut
off and all been dumped on a road and
they would take them to the Morgan
Monterrey and arrived in the morgue.
I was inside.
The more just smelling the smell of the
dead bodies is kind of weird smell you
get from like decaying flesh,
kind of a sweet smell you get from when
you around those places where you can
smell that the board is the cane and
I was inside the Morgan a came out is
outside the morgue and
she was trying to see if,
if her son might be among those people,
among those bodies.
Wow.
No,
it's,
it's so insane that this is right next
door to America and there's so little
effort put on doing something about it,
including doing something to mitigate
the influence of illegal drugs by making
drugs legal. And that would
be one gigantic step. You're,
you're not going to stop people from
doing drugs. I mean, this is an illogical,
ridiculous approach. I don't think
people should do most of those drugs,
but when you make drugs illegal, only
criminals are going to sell those drugs.
And this is exactly what you
have right next door to American.
It's just unbelievably insane
that there's this amount of crime,
a drive away from San Antonio.